Kylie Jenner getting real about her life
in the spotlight and opening up about
coping with her high-profile breakup I
feel like I'm in a relationship with the
world sometimes Kylie appears depressed
about her dating life on the latest
episode of life of Kylie and dad Caitlyn
Jenner can't seem to lift her spirits we
got to do something you can't sit around
here and mope the hardest part about
having a relationship for me is just
that it's blasted all over the internet
you have to hear about other people's
opinions on who you're with it's a lot
while her on-and-off relationship with
ex Tyga has now come to a close that's
not the only big change in the beauty
gurus world I feel like I'm getting into
so many cool beauty things I'm excited
about it in another new sneak peek at
her spin off the 20 year old reality
star admits she's also fed up with her
old hairstyle choices you'll recall
Kylie has made several colorful hair
choices over the years I don't want to
be a weirdo I don't want to pull up a
purple hair I'm over it I'm over Keeping
Up with this lifestyle of crazy hair and
ways
[Music]
you